it is um just after we can make us say I
know
yes every time yeah yeah
you'd be better with a silhouette person
again
if we can address each other by our
female names I know it is a bit
difficult for us and we often fall back
into the habit of Christian mental if we
could use our title it's only been handy
for the recording and people watching
um well first of all then
um item number one apologies for absence
Tucker
um I was told there was going to be a
substitute but I don't know George
counselor Watson and councilor
Pennington's substituting
thank you very much I met you as you say
I know that um
David wooden and there was Jeremy
absolutely I was just dealing with
apologies for me so I did to say you
were about to come
hopefully Council of warden will be with
us soon and the substitute for Council
attacker
um answer number two then should be the
minutes of the previous reading held on
the first of November 2020 to their
attached
um which normally used to impressed by
Page
anything please do a page first of all
page five
Page Six
page seven
page eight
um
control
on my recollection also I proposed a
resolution
I'm not sure technically whether and any
resolution that is not carried is
normally recorded in the minutes
um certainly um
we normally put the votes in chair
whether it's carried
or something
worth checking okay
okay uh page number nine
and ten
from family 13 11.
would somebody please propose that we
accept those minutes as a true effort
thank you very much in favor
yeah
anyone again thank you that's Karen
um
just wondering how you access the
YouTube record of the minute of the
meetings is the public informed
about that
come on come on see the meetings on
YouTube later there's been live streamed
at the moment yes on YouTube so the link
is on in the true cancer sites I just
wondering how it will informed the
public is about that really how to
access them the video record of the
meeting
his sister's on the front of the agenda
and if you go onto our website
all right
yeah okay thank you okay thank you very
much
um Declarations of Interest
Ing and item number five uh to agree
with the agenda if you know there is
nothing in B is that agreed
thank you very much
um
[Music]
can I just their own introductions so
thank you to the officers because I
think we've got two really really good
especially the second report which is so
sour and looks at all the options that
will be open for us and I just want to
say thank you for the for the work and
the contribution to the rest is because
it is First Rate
um piece of work
giving us all the information that we're
going to need today so I would just want
to put that on record thank you very
much I know it's been torturous
um but I think you know it's really
really is valuable for us to have it all
in front of us laid out well today
so item number six of the proposals
um for the reforms
um to the National planning film and
planning reforms generally
um
okay
um good morning councilors
so
um
so I'm sure most of you will be aware
that the government is currently
Consulting on reforms to National
planning policy together with the
progression of a wider program of
legislative reforms being taken forward
under the leveling up and regeneration
bill now that the consultation
were published on the 22nd of December
and the consultation closes on the 2nd
of March this is an extensive
the range of consultation material and
um there are 58 specific questions set
out within the proposed reform now I
thought it might be helpful if I just
give you a feel for what those questions
look like
um so I've just got a range just just to
read out so you can get an understanding
of the kind of questions that are being
posed through the conversation
so one thing do you
do you agree that local planning
authorities should not have to
continually demonstrate a deliverable
five-year housing land Supply as well as
the housing requirements set out in its
strategic policies is less than five
years old so that's just an example
um do you have any views about the
potential changes to paragraph 14 of the
existing framework and increasing
protection given to Neighborhood plans
and is there anything else that you
think would help Community groups in
delivering affordable housing on
exception sites
um do you agree in principle that an
applicant's past Behavior should be
taken into account into decision making
and do you agree with making changes to
emphasize the role of beauty and place
making in strategic policies and to
further encourage well-designed and
beautiful development
do you agree that this is the a lot of
them refer to proposals so you would
ultimately need to read them in that
context but do you agree that this is
the right approach making sure that the
food production value of high value
Farmland is adequately weighted in the
planning process
um a further area that forms a large
part is sort of tackling climate change
and one of the questions is what method
or measure could provide a proportionate
and effective means of undertaking a
carbon impact assessment that would
incorporate all measurable carbon demand
created from plan making and planning
decisions and
and then there's a further one so as
part of the measures there's a proposal
for National development management
policies and there's a general question
asking for views on the suggested scope
and principles for guiding those so that
just gives you a sort of snapshot there
are 58 questions and the expectation is
that a response would would be provided
to all of those
um
it is important to read to sort of
understand this consultation in in The
Wider context of changes being taken
more forward under the leveling up and
regeneration bill
so sort of looking more more
specifically at the elements
firstly the consultation is seeking
views on specific proposals for media
short-term changes to introduce into
planning policy in Spring this year
um Power 4.4 of your agenda so page 14
of your agenda paragraph 3.4 summarizes
at points a to H what those key
components are of the short-term changes
to National planning policy and I won't
run through all of those now
um secondly there is a series of
significant wider proposals and these
would be taken forward in association
with and to follow Royal Ascent of the
leveling up and regeneration bill with
these delaying the current time table
being to implement these towards the end
of 2024.
um it's the most specifically the focus
of these wider proposals is
um
to make sure that the planning system
capitalizes on opportunities to support
the natural environment responds to
climate change and delivers on leveling
up of Economic Opportunity and also set
out is how the government expects to
consider
in the context of the Rider review of
the national planning policy framework
and the introduction of national
development management policies now the
the reason you will have seen in the the
second main item on your agenda there
are elements of these proposals that do
have a potential bearing on plan making
and obviously you're here to consider
the review of the local plan today
um I'm not going to go into diesel on
those now because Dawn and Liz will be
covering those in their presentation and
those matters that could be of greatest
relevance to to plan making in the
future
um it is sort of important to note in
the short term there are potential
changes to five year land five year
housing around the supply with the the
current proposal and the draft National
planning policy framework being to if
you have an adopted plan you're
protected for five years from adoption
so our five-year adoption period would
be the end of October this year so were
that to come forward in the spring of
this year then that could immediately
address and I say could because these
are still draft proposals but like I
said my colleagues will come on to that
in more detail should you have any
questions
consultation
um
the the scope of it is far-reaching and
there will be an effect on both plan
making across North Devon and torridge
and decision taking
um
you know it covers many aspects of the
planning system it's therefore really
important for for Australia's councils
members and officers to carefully
consider the potential implications of
the consultation and ensure that
comments are made within the deadline
the proposals potentially have
significant implications for Northern
Devon and and Lewis officers recognize
the importance of any response
reflecting elected members views
and
what we're there for
propose
um is and recognize it is to seek to
arrange sessions to go through proposals
and make sure that any response on
behalf of the councils is informed by
members and it's considered that the
joint planning policy committee is the
most effective vehicle to gain to gain
members perspectives and to to help
inform the formal consultation response
so just just finally so the
recommendation before you has set out a
paragraph 2.1 of of the Agenda Report is
that Arrangements be made for members of
The Joint planning policy committee to
meet to explore the government's
National planning reform proposals and
to inform a formal response from the
councils to the government's Associated
consultation thank you
thank you Helen um
colleague said the recommendation
I mean is I'm in your hands would you
rather if we did meet would you rather
meet face to face or try to do something
um virtually
would you prefer face to face because I
think that I've seen nods around the
room yeah time's short
um do we need I'm I'm looking to
colleagues do we need we've got the
power to respond on behalf of the two
councils
because I suppose each council is being
consulted then firmly as a council
so can I mean
presumably this is the right vehicles
and that's for us to
um
you know appointed to do the job
therefore I think we should do because
once you go to people outside this
committee they won't necessarily have
the grasp of all the facts so I think it
has to come from within this committee
I'm happy to propose it if you want a
proposal thank you councilor James has
proposed that this committee got cancer
thank you thank you Council thank you
Jeremy Jeremy absolutely
I know it's it's it's painful and and
awkward to find dates wouldn't it be
better to try to agree a date today
while we're together because time was
short we've literally only got
um you know two or three weeks to get
this
but it would have been added to try to
look at our diaries now
um I'm looking to sell John and Helen
about real availability
um and we had teams
and obviously a bit of preparation
talking about I imagine most of it's to
hand
in terms of yeah
I would envisage that any first session
members would be provided with something
in advance there is you know it's open
to you to review the whole consultation
document that there would be to make it
as useful as possible a need for some
preparation before that meeting and
officers can can facilitate with that
very much I mean basically around about
half term are gone but the big the
beginning of the 13th of February is
half term week which is difficult I know
for some of the officers so we'll be
looking at the week after the week
beginning the 20th okay are we
connecting the 20th
are there any days that that are
impossible for folk or anybody like to
so one of the days in the week beginning
the 20th into the into the ring
I won't be here
I fly
abroad on the 18th
of February for two weeks so
I'm sorry could we have a nice
substitute would you be happy yeah okay
thank you
anyways
um cancer patches looking at our
committee program for that week the sort
of latter part of the week so the
Thursday or the Friday would be better I
appreciate that is tight but I think
we'd have to use that as probably the
sole productive session
it's first impossible
yeah
are we talking about tragedy three it's
the 23rd yes yeah that's a positive
development in the morning
the first regeneration board is in the
morning isn't it also so it looks like
it'd be either the Thursday or Friday
afternoon Thursday afternoon
no
all right
11 o'clock
more policy committee
I wish I I wish I had an introduced
away and try to do a David pole and see
if we can actually find it
in the meetings if that helps or no tea
time on the third stamina you know
foreign
[Music]
to remove them into item number seven
um
which is the the options Report with the
recommendation that we do the partial
review now of the local plan
um who's going to lead on this one
okay
um
it's quite an extensive support and what
we've tried to provide two members is
all the information that we've gathered
from a range of
sources to be them to make her an
informed decision
so
yeah okay so
um as members
you know from previous meetings of this
committee and an informal energy of this
committee
officers have been tasked with the
viewing the council's 2020 decision can
you bring the mic towards you a bit
please
temperature
um so I'll just repeat that for benefit
of members so officers have been tasked
with the viewing the Council of 2020
decision to undertake a comprehensive
review of the plan
as previously reported there have been a
range of factors both internal and
external that have prompted this review
which include a slippage and initially
established program of work that would
impact on the timetable the eventual
submission of the local plan
pushes on local government finances
which everybody has whether well aware
of
and certainties relating to planning
reforms which
um Helen has just indicated and
consideration of changing local
priorities
moving on
um
two in front of the view an extensive
program of work
as members will see from the agenda has
been undertaken and it's indicated in
the slide before you so there's been a
technical review of
um plan program provided by officers
through the past toolkits which provided
as part of the agenda
and pairs who Consultants have provided
an external review
and members
um both this committee and more widely
have been engaged to gain their views as
how we should progress with the plan and
the issues that are of concern to them
so
just reflecting on the Paz toolkit
um overall we can see that the plan is
generally working well
targets of being met decisions are
generally made which deliver policy
compliant developments
and the strategy came some objectives of
the plan they're being achieved a
special strategy in terms of development
and distribution continue to remain
valid
again as members I'm more than aware we
do have an issue in terms of our
five-year housing runs upon
which is called is problematic
and that some decisions are having to be
made
which are outside the planned bed
approach
um
and I think that it seems to be
particularly impactful on some of our
smaller settlements
I'm certainly in college that seems to
be seems to be seems to be the case
it's very just if there's no good back
to the previous slide
um
part of the second part of the toolkit
looks at
compliance with national policy and
which is a significant issue
so when the plan was submitted and then
adopted it was judged against
2012 National planning policy framework
clearly things have changed in terms of
national guidance since that time so the
main areas of um now compliance in front
of the local plan other than five year
housing land Supply relate to matters
which
current national planning policy
and now they're quite the plan to look
at so it's by a mission rather than
um conflict I would suggest
yes the other next slide please
so I've indicated before to help us
income to a viewing on the toolkits
um third party was engaged to give
oversight as to work through the
undertaking
and generally speaking that just
confirmed the work that officers have
undertaken the plan was working well but
there's an issue in terms of five-year
loan Supply
also who has engagement identified the
range of issues and through that members
ways
particularly in terms of delivery of
afford for housing
and viability issues
which were impacting on Hunting
obligations that were coming forward
through
development and planning consents
because
um again
the um sorry apologies to members the
full report of
um
has is provided as appendix free
um so in the court itself for the
highlights with recommendations and key
observations but the full report is
provided for members to The View as part
of the report itself
so it just deflects on issues which are
wider than those taken up in the
officers has
toolkits so it reflects all my shoes and
that lumps presented through the
workshop and through the survey
and wouldn't have sort of key conclusion
I would as highlighted is that to
indicate it's probably not the right
time to prepare the new local Farm
um
excuse me
and think and remain the reasons for
that is that the uncertainties in terms
of National Crime National Bank policy
so it will be about to form members to
come to a view on that but the outcomes
from the
Consultants employed by
has generally the flex support officers
provided in in terms of a technical
piece of work
if we can move on please
so I think this just sort of summarizes
what I've just indicated that
has a suggesting it's not the right time
to take a comprehensive plan
to note that at the time Paz made these
recommendations the government had not
issued
um
the proposed consultation in terms of
new National planning policy and future
legislation
but it's the quite clearly indicated
sort of range of issues
um
well indicates that at the time their
recommendation was not prudent to
undertake the comprehensive few and that
an alternative approach to the past with
a few could be undertaken to address the
issues which have been highlighted
it also suggests
um that you know you could wait and see
um perhaps not undertake action at the
moment
but consider
when there's more certainty what the
councils might best undertake it in
terms of the course of action
thank you hun
so clearly a key consideration in terms
of how how we move forward
um in terms of the plans is members
issues
um
and the slide here indicates
the general outcomes of surveying
workshops and again it was reassuring to
understand that members of the plan was
working well
but clearly there are some issues and
members have concerns
obviously the plan was prepared some
time ago and we are in the changing
environment with in terms of little
qualities and in terms of what we've
been asked to do by governments so it's
not surprising that members have issues
that and they feel perhaps could be
better addressed through the review or
an updates of the local plan
if you can move forward through time
so
this slide just indicates the wide range
of issues that
um
well simplified I would say a sort of
priority matters that's members would
wish to see
addressed through any form of review or
update
to the local plan
and you know they are wide-ranging and
whatever way members
decide to move forward these issues can
be looked at clearly if we go down the
partial View
approach
for scoop to make change will be limited
um
to put another Focus
these options can be investigated by
officers
a comprehensive review would enable
all matters to be considered
um
thank you Helen
but I'm just going to pass on the next
section of the report to my weekly
little 22
um navigate you through the um
issues that are raised through the
planning the forms that having 50
discussed
in the first agenda item
thank you John
um
as we've already covered the government
launched the leveling up planning
reforms consultation on the 22nd of
December and this is after the worker
concluded with pairs both on the
toolkits and and the member workshops
um and the contacts are coming to review
on the way forward to the local plan
it's important to understand the
implications for her plan making
perspective
all right
and it's Helen out loud earlier there
are some short-term challenges which
will come into effect potentially in the
spring through the
updates the national planning policy
framework
and then further changes will be
implemented
potentially by the government by the end
of 2024
so if we look at the short-term changes
first
um a key point for members to be aware
of is the challenge to have value
housing around the supply policy is a
plot is applied
as you know at the present time
and I like the 10 over 40 can
demonstrate
the fabulary line to play this can be
challenged at any point by an applicant
um what the government are proposing is
to secure the family housing land supply
for a period of five years from the date
of the adoption of the local plan so for
us it was five years from the 29th of
October 2018.
um a vegetables and councils not having
to defend the supply position at a pill
and relieving the need to apply return
to balance the decision-making purposes
if if the councils are unable to
demonstrate the ideal land Supply
which is our current position
in addition subject to formal review of
strategic policies which has to be
undertaken within five years of adoption
of a local plan the draft mpps would
also allow for the five-year Line supply
position I can't say that to be set for
a further five years
so you'd have your first five years from
a relative adoption you do a strategic
review of policies and as long as um
that includes you can demonstrate you
have adequate housing land Supply at
that time then it's secure for another
five years after that
um and and just to mention that uh
re-establishment of the five year
housing allowance of flowers one of the
key drivers for for updating the current
local plan because obviously we've had
issues with that over the past few years
uh moving them as I say
proposals also look to introduce changes
in relation to wind energy developments
um
so to ensure that planning permission
for wind energy is based on satisfactory
satisfactorily addressing the planning
impacts of one children's projects would
identified by local communities and will
be subjected
demonstrating local support for the
scheme
so this is basically mean that it
removes the overly rigid requirement and
I think that's government speak to
designate areas within an existing local
plan
whatever one other change is in relation
to plan making
um
the government proposes removing one of
the test of soundness
which he used to examine local plans
so they were proposing to remove the
test So the plan is Justified
and
puts the current mppf defines as being
an appropriate strategy taking into
account the reasonable Alternatives and
based on proportionate evidence
no this basically means that we should
remove
the obligation to prepare significant
evidence alongside a local plan and his
members may be aware of this this is
what takes a lot of time and um
and funds to do
um
however offices are a little I'm sure
that this will have this work in
practice given there are still
obligations Within
the
mppf is
to stop this particular approaches
through plan making which can only be
understood by having that evidence-based
in place so for example in relation to
housing Supply and what the housing need
is and the types of houses it has houses
needed
um and then in the medium term there's a
range of proposals relating to the
natural environment
um how to respond to climate change and
how to deliver leveling up
um if we move on to the next slide thank
you so again this is just going through
the
timetable
um
basically if we were to
introduce a new style local plan
which would be much more slimmed down
sorry that would need to be adopted with
around 30
amounts of commencing it in November
um
timetables that turned out to be what is
likely to be challenging especially for
the front running local authorities who
want to take the work
um from experience from
when the previous local plan process was
put in place inspectors can be very
harsh very challenging on what's
expected
as best practice hasn't been put in
place already
um and alongside this slowing down local
plan is Helen mentioned earlier there
would be development management policies
at a national level
um
these would be afforded the same weight
as the development plan in this decision
taking
um
hello the local planning authorities are
would be able to retain the ability to
prepare their own local plan policies on
local issues
that would not be allowed to duplicate
policies in the National
development management
looked to duplicate policies which are
in the National policies document
um
in terms of transitional arrangements
for these proposals if we continue to
prepare an old style local plan
this has to be submitted to the
government by June 2025 and are adopted
by December 2026
and that would apply if we were doing a
comprehensive update to a local plan or
a partial review so we'd have to submit
either of those pieces of work by June
2025 or alternatively as I just
mentioned if you start work
and released so make the plan that would
commence in 2024 and we would have 13
months to do so
to adopt
okay if we move forward so we head into
the next slide
so towards the way forward
um his dad has gone through most of the
liquor plan the manuscript for purpose
um however there are some emissions and
areas of non-conformity and table one of
appendix e outlines those matters
um and again members have raised areas
of concern but these aren't
necessarily due to the provisions of the
local plan we could look to implement
those in a different way
or look to address those in a different
way until we see if appendixes looks
looks at those issues
but we do need to recognize there are so
significant uncertainties
given the changes changes to National
planning policy and the big element
known for the councils at the moment is
the position of the Fairview housing
land Supply
um
workers currently
being undertaken to establish whether
the councils will do have one we'll have
one
um and that should be work should be
completed in the coming months
um so at this stage it's important to
emphasize that we don't actually know
what that outcome will be whether we
will be able to demonstrate a five-year
Line supply or not
um again that
is the mgps
proposals with
could potentially come into play in
relation to we wouldn't need to be
demonstrating that because after five
years
our plan was adopted within the past
five years and that was Remain the case
until the 29th of October this year
um but obviously the government's
proposals are subject to change
no
um
in relation to the fact you're around
Supply
it may be that if we are
if if there was a short teaching again I
emphasize we do not know at this point
if it's only a moderate
level of Supply which is required that
potentially could be addressed through a
partial update through looking to
allocate further small housing
allocations but if it's a if it's a
larger amount
Supply which is required
then that would go to the heart of the
strategy of a local plan and that would
mean that a comprehensive local plan
would be necessary to be undertaken
so if we move forward getting Helen to
the next slide so this is a slide which
tries to summarize the the
options available to to the councils we
can either
focus in on the key issues at the moment
so
over through looking at how we're
implementing a current local plan would
be that through additional supplementary
planning documents through additional
work with development management
colleagues and other colleagues
throughout the councils
um preparing potentially a partial
review
which could address matters such as
development management policies
potentially renewable energy
approach and looking for small business
allocations moving through to the
biggest option largest option which is
the more comprehensive review of the
local plan
and if we move forward to the next slide
please Helen
thank you and
annual reports on pages 31 to 37 World
tables which set out in detail
what each of the different potential
options we have for us to
to consider and the pros and cons of
each
so if I go a few days quickly
if I go through them in the order in the
in the report we have a comprehensive
update so as I've just mentioned this
would
this would could look at strategic
issues
um and basically there'll be an
opportunity to develop and remains
the approach the strategies and policies
and the whole of the of the local plan
so basically we can start again
and we can change the base dates of the
plan as well because it currently only
goes up to
20 31
obviously the cost of doing this would
be significant
and there's the risk that we have until
middle of June 25 to submit for
the plan to the government to obviously
our studies for us a very tight timeline
if we then look at the next two options
there's a partial update which could be
done through either incorporating it
into an existing plan
to Integrity existing local plan
through a separate development plan
documents so
so if we do it through the
existing local plan then we would just
add in sections
update the text
addressing those matters which of which
I'll keep concerned to members in those
areas which has been highlighted through
the past work
which I admitted at the moment
um
well there is a risk to a partial review
in terms of
whether the scope would be acceptable to
the planning Spectrum
give them the 15-year plan period from
the point of adoption issue which I
raised just now that we have seen in
recent days
um
a report an inspector's report
for a partial review for bathroom
Northeast somersets local plan which has
allowed a
shorter time frame from the 15 years to
be acceptable
given their particular circumstances so
this is something which officers can
investigate more
um
to ensure that it can take place
then obviously we could wait
for a new Fair local plan and in the
into room
look to
improve how the current local plan is
implemented to address issues members of
have raised through the workshops
or alternatively you could just focus
on improving
the Implement implementation of the
local plan at this point
um
so if you move on Helen
recommendations are set out in
paragraphs 2.1 and 2.2 of your reports
uh two point
and screen is the
recommendation which is referred
which is a balanced for jppc to
recommend for free councils of NDC and
qdc to move to a targeted and focused
special update to the ndtip
the potential scope of which is indicate
indicatively set out in appendix 5 as a
specifically explores opportunities to
address those issues set out
through one to four or the alternative
is for jppc to recommend
an alternative preferred approach
thank you thank you
for that um
members the recommendation is up on the
screen at the moment that we take the
partial review option I must say looking
at Targets at June 2025 Mary sugar demon
spy
because I think just realistically we
just wouldn't be able to make it well
I'm quite puzzled by it's the idea of
national
um
um development policies
now I'm trying to measure much of the
flavor they might have
um you have the other issue is of course
that we we're gonna we're gonna be first
with short-term changes
um that may well help our situation in
terms of the five-day land Supply and
the putting the the other changes
buffered out against the general
election makes them problematic I really
I think we've got to sort of put them to
one side because they know or may not
happen so you know I expect the short
term and ones are the ones we've really
ought to focus our minds on in making
our decision today
um but colleagues
yes that's right yeah
just bringing
any wording that needs updating any and
the rural issues perhaps we could take
all would not alter the full plan I
think we need to be careful not to be
too um uh be too extensive as you've
said we've got a period of change in
front of us perhaps but to address those
short-term issues quickly and make sure
we you know our plan is going to be
in place and and viable so that we can
continue with it without
impact from government
thank you thank you Jim
Council
um I've gone through this 17 times over
the last couple of weeks I'm as confused
today as always
we're looking at the I'm just wondering
what are we trying to achieve with a
partial review what items are we looking
at we're also looking at the time scale
because we're doing that we are not
moving towards a review in the orphan of
a full review to get that underway
because obviously Staffing there's an
issue and resources and I'll just worry
that if we go down the road with a
partial review the things I'm interested
in it's just the real policies which
when we go back to having a Five-Year
Plan it's not going to do us any good at
all in the real world area
and some of the stuff I've picked up on
the last few days which I won't go into
I think Solomon in this area is going to
become quite difficult shortly
of course a hex May reflect the rumors
that there's going to be some changes in
the income on farms and so I'm just
wondering
are we going to achieve what have you
got in mind in a partial review in
pension in some points rather than you
know they do it partially with the what
we do in a partial review of and how we
can achieve anything which would be not
much is us against me and I've argued
that there are officers the complete
officer are about to see a partial
review but the rural policy is excluded
from the partial review I was for
um bios diversity stuff is excluded but
there will be work being done in the
Autumn anyway and the five year land
Supply that is an ongoing project as
well so you know are we going to be
diverting resources to doing a partial
review then long term yeah the last
policy we spent about eight or nine
years discussing it and it got pushed
through in a month or two and they were
picking up the problems perhaps it would
be much better to put our resources to
planning for the future albeit in many
of us for what they have rather than a
short fix which you can't do you know
it's quite specific in the criteria we
can't do a partial review on some of the
rural policies because they will be
guided by the five year land Supply so
I'm just wondering what are you hoping
to achieve with a partial review other
than stretching resources
thank you chair I'm sorry for you but
I'm trying to take much longer positive
view if they were going
thank you Ken I'm sorry cancer you know
I share a level of your concerns about
some of the real issues but I think that
we've got to be Innovative about tacking
some of those and using probably a
mixture of
um neighborhood planning and perhaps
supplementary planning to see how we can
help some of those communities that do
well they do want some growth and I I
completely agree with you
I just think that if we go through the
full review we're putting up those
changes that will need in the real it
was probably five years
um you know which I don't think is
acceptable I think you write about the
changes in agriculture there's a whole
raft of
um Farmers that have got no idea what's
coming around the corner for them and I
think that women are buried their heads
in the sand
um with the loss of a lot of income
coming
um so I think you're certainly right and
I think those those are wider than just
this local plan we can't tackle
agriculture of the problems that I've
got from the face solely in this plan so
any other actions that we take from an
economic development point of view are
really important for the rural areas I
said that too but I don't come in the
same conclusion as you can I don't think
that we can afford to put enough
um and any changes that you and I want
to see for the you know that an impact
the rural areas I think we can do more
quickly and more effectively in a
reasonable time frame through through
the partial review rather than the
complete comprehensive I'll just take
cancer cancer spare and then I can't say
yes what you said about agriculture the
government now has published its policy
hasn't it and it's it's saying was gone
how it affects the economy and also
climate change in the environment
um first looking at that person it does
tend to
support large large Farms but that's not
what we've got in northern northern
Devon isn't so I do think we all have a
good look at that document we now know
what the government policy apparently is
just to Carry On from cancer Spirit I'm
I'm I'm a SFI pilot member
I suppose but
we're still developing a government
still developing policies for the SFI
scheme it is now open but we're still
the pilot members are still developing
policies and they're way way way off
achieving what most of what they want to
achieve and the commercial sector of the
farming industry I'm sure my colleague
over here can in can assist they are
basically saying stuff at we're just
being commercial and they're not even
doing what they were doing before so
there's no no margins
so we're actually going backwards in
terms of of nature recovery because they
cannot they can't get anything out of
the new scheme so they're not going to
bother it
somewhere anyway to be quite honest but
they're the commercial people bigger
people they're making money so they
don't they're not interested so people
trap the small Family Farms who relying
on the subsidy schemes to survive there
are quite a few of them but my sense is
that it's all aimed at the bigger units
because they've got the room to do what
is required and they can pay somebody to
do the paperwork
I can see farming even in Devon
just going down a commercial route and
sucking up everything else and in fact
we've gone backwards to be honest except
for those few smaller units who are
focusing on nature recovery I've just
joined the
um
tall tall Valley and little dark
attachment area group it was a big
meeting last night which I couldn't get
because I was a parish counselor but
that's quite interesting for someone
who's not wanting to be too commercial
with farming
there's a real divide I'll stop there
because I'm sure somebody else can do
that better I just want to go back
chairman to the recommendations I I
prefer the language
for what we're talking about here uh
update goals and
anything else because it is updating
what we've got putting it right
changing it a bit especially what the
recommendations are I think so I would
be supporting the recommendations
thank you Council councilman
well I've got the support Council of the
absolutely to a large extent on this one
agriculture is starting to take a hiding
these stewardship schemes that the
government has introduced
are okay for the green farmer who is
quite happy to sort of wander around
with the dog and stick and produce
little or nothing
the commercial boys don't want to know
it
because it's intrudes on their method of
farming to an extent that they just
can't afford to do it
now you might say oh we're making money
they've had a good
12 months
I saw a letter last night
where our biggest
cheese producer in the area
was from yesterday reducing their price
by nine Phillips and liter
that is I don't know what it is 20 drop
overnight
now
the last time we saw drops like this was
the 20s a hundred years ago
and I want to play fine shambles it was
after that
now on the other side of the coin we've
got a local plan
which is being so careful so restrictive
we've got the environment agency telling
Farmers they've got to cover their um
slowly
cattle walking areas
we've got the punishment from the middle
of an application to to cover it to
satisfy the environment agency
it's immense
and we've really got to sort things out
because you're just gonna drive people
out to the extent that I plead guilty
the cat that I have on my small farm
of the Mask we should be having
they will be carried about this spring
and I'm selling the grass I can't be
putting up with it
it's a pretty it's a pretty Grim picture
who is he doing again but um
I just want to ask a bit about this five
year land Supply because it's one of the
biggest mysteries it's a bit like
waiting for Sunday night with Strictly
Come Dancing isn't it to see who's going
to be in the final I I get the hints
that we I mean it's been marginal for a
long time but there was a bit of
optimism I feel in the areas or not
um in which case you know the the huge
review that I think some of us thought
was needed in terms of land allocation
may not now be the case but that's
speculation
um but um you know we I think Liz or
dawn said about in the coming months we
need we need to know in a matter of
weeks now don't we we're going to be a
mahila panel you know remember the scope
of its work is is going to be much more
limited if Mary if my
how much is right but I don't know
whether you're going to be doing on that
um
weeks is not possible in terms of the
outcome of this exercise a lot of
resources being pushed put towards
um trying to provide that will provide
an understanding of put the five year
land Supply position is
um as members are aware it's incredibly
frustrating that within this position
our blood supply in terms of allocations
sites that the councils have granted
consent on way exceeds the actual
requirements
provided by the plan so the requirement
is somewhere over just seven is
somewhere over 17 000 units
the last count of the supply exceeded
twenty two thousand yeah it's not about
um
the opportunities that have been
the opportunity is there for the
development industry to develop to come
forward
and it's just not taking it up it's all
about delivery it's not about Supply
um
with the current housing market you're
going to be have a even more of a
barrier from the national house builders
the American land banking thinking three
full years ahead again like it was six
seven eight years ago so we that
situation ain't going to improved is
going to get worse
there's been a lot of commentary of late
about some of our national house
builders and
looking to the store sites or not for
this site as um promptly as they had
anticipated and
um this I would expect would be the
Fletcher through the outcomes of
discussion through the Gila panels
um
but as indicated before it's not through
the want of opportunity to the industry
it seems for you is not coming forward
with the sites or it hasn't done so in
the past
but I think from the work that was
undertaken as
presented in the toolkits
um there are sites across both districts
that are now progressing
um
to the point
um of you know full application for surf
matters development is occurring on site
so we're in a better position than when
we looked at the last five years
um if we go to the over that Tipping
Point
that's a different programs you can put
Tipping Point yeah
um anyway so that's something that we'll
have to sort of I just think I just
think
um the million members understand that
because I I don't I don't think the
situation is as dire
as some people think I'm literally
thought I made this comment I think to
Helen into Sarah Jane that you see some
of these inspect very small applications
but the inspector when it's coming to
make to certainly the inspector at
making decisions is is putting them
inside the lack of a 50 land Supply in
another cases now so that's interesting
so I think that's probably because of
their government's announcement so I
think you know what we're going to do is
to decide
where is the best way to tackle some of
those problems we know in the local plan
without throwing the baby over the
bathwater and I think you know that's
that's where I am at the moment
um and I haven't had anything yet to to
dissuade me from that view but members
come back here I'll hold you so alone
but yeah my point but also
I say anything
it's not all about agriculture yeah I am
a dog and stick finder these days my
wife keeps three shoot now where the
hell she keeps three sheep I don't know
but
the point is is a wider economy and
there is income training within that
economy now within the local plan at the
moment can officers confirm them that if
we looked at the rural
planning policy
within the current structure that it can
be looked at because it quite clearly
says in the
the or the stuff we've had they they're
very well economy cannot be dealt
without it being dealt with with a full
review so if it can't be dealt with it
means we're going to spend time looking
at it then we should be preparing to
deal with the issues properly full time
because I keep hearing myself a partial
review of
a partial review
you look at the Helen and Sarah Jane I
mean I I I mean I'm looking at some of
the badly I mean obviously
from from North Devonshire I mean we are
one Luna in terms of Economic
Development and strategic planning and I
think you know there's more that can be
done within the economic development
field than we're doing at the moment
yeah I mean I think in terms of the
scope of any partial update we need to
draw members attention to appendix e
which is a set out on the papers because
that's where it's identifying what we
can and can't do through the pattern I
think that's the papers cancer James
that you're referencing isn't it
um there is an element within that table
that looks at the rural strategy and uh
housing and economy so
just looking at economy
um so it's saying need to provide more
employment learning rural areas both
with settlements and in the countryside
and the solution is saying that the
local plan already provides for wine
ranging opportunities for the expansion
of new of and new rural Enterprises and
so it's identified that actually we
could be addressing that
through matters either outside of the
Plan update all through a partial update
or comprehensive review which is how
it's set out so I think that's really
looking at the policies that we have and
how we might apply them differently
um
it there's been an area around
um the use of buildings in the
countryside which again is tackling how
we would identify existing policies and
then there's a section around rural
tourism
and again looks at the application of
existing policies so on the world
economy section
it's actually saying that the policy
context and framework is there within
the existing plan as I read it it's just
how we then apply those policies there's
rural housing that is different and with
rural housing
um
it is suggesting that we'd have to do
that through a comprehensive update and
I would seek the views of Dawn and Liz
in that regard it's not suggesting we
could do it deal with it another world
or I do wonder whether a neighborhood
planning process might be able to
support us a little bit in that regard
um but I do think in terms of scope and
it's a point that officers have made to
members that appendix is is really vital
because that is where it's identifying
what we can and can't do through the
various options that have been presented
to you today and so I would urge you to
have a look at that and ask any
questions boxes that you have but yeah
that's just reiterating cancer days
whether it says in that regard I don't
know if if Helen Dawn always want to add
to that thanks and yeah the chair if I
can just come in
um Sarah Jane's absolutely right to
direct you to that appendix it is key in
understanding
um what can and can't be done and the
issues that are specifically set out
both relate the non-conformity okay so
the issues that have come out through
the toolkit where the plan is not in
Conformity with subsequent changes to
National policy but also importantly
it's all the issues that you as members
and The Wider membership have raised
through the workshops and those being
important and and in members eyes
requiring review and so yeah as Sarah
Jones says the rural strategy economy
and the rural economy are set out within
the appendix raw strategy economy it's
indicating
could be like could be addressed the
concerns could be addressed both outside
of a plan up day as a partial update and
as a comprehensive update so it really
then comes down to the detail of what
members want to see achieved and you
know we're we're all strategy economy
per se it would depend on what it was
and how that could be addressed and
we'll tourism again it's similar there's
elements that could be addressed through
a comprehensive review elements that
could potentially be addressed through a
partial review but it doesn't go into
the detail of what that would look like
the appendix
um agriculture
it does it has question marks against
what could be achieved and there's an
indication that
um
further work is needed to establish the
detailed policy matters which could be
addressed or whether these matters can
be dealt with outside with the system so
it doesn't it doesn't put the curvy in
terms of Agriculture and obviously as as
members have already raised that is a
very quickly changing context and it is
important that that is is looked at and
we support our rural economy in the
agricultural sense so
um it's it's even though this is here
and it does give give an idea of scope
there's still a level underneath to
understand what really could and
couldn't be achieved but I would totally
agree this is this is a key bit of
information for you in understanding the
scope and therefore the value of the
partial review and there are lots of
ticks in the partial plan update columns
so there is work that could be done
Council Pennington and cancer
conversation backwards now because you
moved out every agricultural issue
just a little bit concerned because the
tolerance representative committee
there's four of us over six who have
strong agricultural backgrounds and
we're going to have to sell it to our
full Council of next Monday night
so I remember if we had a representative
new representative friend request so
I've got 120 acres and three sevens and
the family farm since 1850 and none of
the sons of undertaken on so it just
puts you in the picture so I'll better
be clear of Interest I suppose really
but interestingly enough I'm very close
to Billy fair but when I hear the
arguments about partner
access to the countryside is going to
become a huge issue given the density of
housing we have in the urban areas and
my Iran starts three quarters of a mile
from this is where I'm sitting there at
the present moment and I've just seen a
huge change in the countryside since the
pandemic basically people who have come
out or even the boats got closed down so
people couldn't go there onto the boats
which is quite surprising to me at the
time and people have got access people
want more access given the density and
interesting because I have a part about
where it is in tourist areas we saw the
laboratory and very touristy a little
changes running opportunities
um and then you come away to the more
rural areas of butford and Eastern
Westfield
um a lot of land we learn 3A you know
the new consultation talks about land
above 3A being protected and keeping for
agriculture but there's another amount
of work that wouldn't fit into 3M and I
think we're facing more problems from
that necessarily a planning system but
the burnings outside right left room and
they were actually bringing the stuff in
so I just remember how we fit that
within the scheme of things
and looking for the future
and agriculture just in this committee I
just remember I don't know it takes us
back to where we were before but I've
tried to take my hat off over the
previous meeting to look at where we
were to be in 2040 because you take a
loan review of what you think Dodge is
going to be the biggest issue is going
to be Broadband because it enables
economic activity in the rural areas
outside Agriculture and that is where we
seem to be having to go to and people
want to come and live here and that is
where we need to be looking at the wider
plan the picture has changed enormously
all the electronic branches I sit around
here when I started with counselves
the glasses my tablets me watering me
call please before I started these days
so we have a changed earlier so much and
the other area changed and this is
really a conflict of interest the fiber
land Supply with a failure of the land
supply has really benefited me
because if I go back to the bearer of
appeal that we lost at talking to him
the farmer who makes or the library
American Service on but the landowner
who owns owns the land agriculture value
and suddenly able to sell it at
residential about it he makes a huge
pickup and it's interesting seeing the
consultation you talk to me about how
you're trying to or how the government's
going to try to grab more of that
percentage of profit is in the situation
but more land value has been more
subsidized by a lack of a five year land
Supply then what I've been paid on on
the RPA systems which is a really
interesting concept between the two so
yeah
I'm really quite glad that we didn't
benefit
um but at the same time too and they
live in a village
[Music]
so so we've seen that change enormously
I mean a lot of the youngsters Mario and
youngsters have moved away apart from
where he works in North Carolina college
and I said to remind you you get an
example a bit of fun I've got 34 days
holiday a year but
you're being in the public sector so
he's quite popular in the public sector
as well he's made that changes so we
have a real concept here about thinking
what is the real long-term situation and
I do believe that we got 2.1 here and I
would like to see something we know yeah
okay we're only going to actually
specific elements what is that specific
element because I think we have to go to
Portland and but I would like to be a
bit specific about what we actually do
look at and how we go from that but
that's my recommendations from that
point of view chair thank you Phil um
before I come without saying I'll just
my heart and soul is bounced and we've
got a local plan with a lot of policies
in it that are no longer fit for purpose
within some of the urban old commercial
centers you know the protection of
certain class uses that are now the
other day who've got um policies on
regeneration sites that and fit the bill
anymore those can all be dealt with
within this partial review framework and
but I think it is important to you know
to say that there are it's not just in
in the rural areas or issues some of our
times need some changes in the local
plan process as well so I think that
that's worth saying
this this fiber an unsurprise thing I
mean
whatever happens it's again the truth
that issue is going to go away so the
issue is not going to be to find
thousands and thousands of new
um housing sites is it or individual
unit sites it is going to be about how
we look at the economy and the
well-being of our people and that's our
biggest problem is tackling the skills
level the amazing death never worse in
in the whole of England along with
Cornwall
um those are the problems and it's those
skills levels that affect wages they
affect the affordability of housing you
know we can't never talk you know
nationalism about second homes and the
housing crisis the best way to solve it
is to get skills and wage levels up
not something that's easier for us to
impact on from trying to do it with the
taxation or second homes and all the
other tools that we may now have
um anyway so I rambled a bit but
councilor homes
yeah
I'm sorry in common with other members I
should imagine
um I'm sort of pretty confused about all
the variables to do with this process
which would be
uh put in the report for very good
reports which the officers have done
um it's like sort of trying to walk
through a cogmar it seems to me but
there we are I mean if one could if
we're going for a partial review
um Zoom Lee
we're so realistic about the dates
weaken at the Target date we can achieve
and the constraints to do with national
planning policy five-year housing and
all the rest of it
um I'm rural
the rural situation has been raised by
various members some of which doesn't
seem to be to be concerned with planning
particularly but it's nevertheless a
highly important aspect of what we're
looking at
um maybe it would we've got this
appendix here where we've got the boxes
something for comments and what is
relevant and what isn't in terms of
partial review
I mean maybe in specific terms perhaps
the officers could
um Enlighten us about certainly the main
headings that we consider which seem to
be climate Renewables affordable housing
infrastructure and the rural tourism
I've isolated here
um of those particular one you know
those
um
those issues
which can which can be dealt with by
partial review and in what way how do we
go about it perhaps if we can get into
those specifics in my health so think
about it
I don't know whether Dawn or someone can
answer that
climate for instance I mean obviously my
main concern is climate like I consider
the present local plan is very weak in
its wording about climate objectives I
also think there should be stronger
there should be targets carbon emission
targets for instance
um the thing is is that possible in a
partial review or I mean for instance if
I can share if you
um in terms of mass relating
um to climate change I think
for many aspects we will struggle in
terms of a partial review but certainly
some things that can be scoped clearly
in terms of the bigger issue of
renewable energy and onshore wind that's
something where the government's
position may be changing
over the next few months as the mpps may
change and that certainly could be
something that we could look through as
part of a partial review perhaps as a
separate dqd
so that was something yeah
we went through a long exercise in terms
of analyzing Landscapes and types so in
terms of renewable energy and
particularly wind you know we've done a
lot of the work so I think you know
that's you know that's there already in
terms of you know partial reviews
reflecting government changes so in
terms of carbon emissions would that be
building regs or the new government
possibly the new government the new
purpose of kicked in and made a huge
impact already on the building industry
and actually have come at a time with
with I must have mentioned that budget
that we had back in the automatically
but their implementation came along with
that with those actually Crews they've
caused a lot of issues for the building
industry as well but they will you know
that will run right but the new building
breaks are going to make a huge impact
in terms of emissions
um to new development sorry what do you
mean by implementation how does that
work out is that in terms of
supplementary planning documents or is
it in terms of training of officers and
counselors or
company we can certainly um to reflect
what government is saying we can
actually go through that exercise of an
SPD in terms of could we not in terms of
renewable energy and wind
yeah in that regard in terms of carbon
emissions though that would rest with
building regulations rather than the
planning system
but implementation I mean it says
several times
about the issues can be dealt with by
implementation
our biggest our biggest problem is about
how we retro fit
manage your efficiency toward our older
housing in there that is our biggest
problem when you analyze our housing
stock across the two authorities
does that mean you consider that
officers are in need of training to to
better understand local plan policies or
to do you feel that's a problem
with that is it not about interpretation
of the policies in terms of development
control and about how we look at
implementation because every policy you
can read more than one way and I mean
that's the reality of life isn't it so
implementation is about how we manage
the development Control process as well
to make sure that we're supporting
communities in the way that we want to I
mean finally sorry can I just go into
the process going forward from here
um how are we going to deal if we do
vote for a partial review how does this
commit how is this committee going to be
involved does it involve more workshops
or what how do we I imagine we'll be
back to that stage again yeah yeah
and we've got a we've got a deadline of
Wednesday 25 did you say for the partial
review sorry yeah
and what happens with the housing if the
five-year allocation isn't um suitable
um did you say something about you have
to go into a comprehensive review
if there's no I mean there are two
states if in the end we we still haven't
got the results of our own internal
review the livelihood is the government
is going to take this away as as which
does change the picture hugely
so either way I think the five year land
Supply is not the big issue that it was
for us a few months back I'm not
underestimating it but I don't think it
is going to be I think it is going to be
it's going to be about how to adapt to
our housing market it's slowed down
that's a problem in terms of
deliverability still
um so what we're gonna have to do is to
do a lot more work I think about make
you know and more and I know that teams
have tried very hard with this difficult
with national husbands but I think we
need to work that's work to be looking
at allocating in future smaller sites
and making sure regional and local
Builders are more involved in them where
you can have a decent dialogue and
deliver what communities want
um anyway that's a busy thing that is an
implementation issue and what we need to
do is to find space and resource for
planners to be able to have those
conversations from before applications
come in
what's been said this morning and and
quite honestly it's a very confusing
picture isn't it at the moment with
um what's likely to happen
government-wise
um we will have a general election
probably next year things could change
again as a result of that
um we've got the agriculture pilot
that's still taking place
etc etc and I think if we did a full
review at this time we would be
um really in the in this situation where
we could be changing it every every
couple of months and which wouldn't be
in my opinion a very sensible use of our
resources because our resources are very
limited
um and to do a full review is going to
actually stretch our planning department
tremendously and so I'm actually happy
to support that recommendation that we
have on on the screen at the moment but
I think it would be a good idea if we
could put a little bit more meat on the
bones and so that then actually Identify
some of the examples of what we're
talking about so that members will be
aware of the areas that we're
specifically going to be looking at
um and so that's you know what my sort
of perception at this time I I share
um Council James's uh you know problems
with with regard to agriculture Etc but
we're in a situation where
um it's you know impossible in my
opinion to do a full review at this time
the a is going to cost too much beat it
and got the resources and thirdly it
could all change as we're going through
um over and over again
the recommendations are on the screen
have got to I mean the agenda
recommendation goes on
um with BC DNA
um
which will give the give the flexibility
to react to changing National positions
and things which I think is is useful
um but but it's it is an unbalanced
recommendation members say I think we've
probably got to the stage where we need
to make our minds up in terms of the
recommendation so in the agenda it does
talk about providers that allow
agnostic side at the moment came from
the James
anyway can I seek a proposition then
please
thank you Cassie actually is that second
yeah okay
okay members
the recommendation of this has been
moved and seconded so I put it into that
reason favorite please show
six and those against
controllers
thank you very much so there's glad it's
carried
um item eight is committing us to dates
for a new Council isn't it
it's to recommend that we recommend that
is suggesting we appreciates for the
three
Community without looking to do report
and we're going to do this
you need a course in a mission don't we
for the next calendar year that there's
a date's not yet we have a March meeting
I think yeah
[Music]
I'm not quite sure and we will
separately arrange them again
idea what the March meeting will be
about
um that'll be for discussion with the
chair and vice chair and I think given
the resolution it would seem sensible to
address some certainly the point you
raise councilor homes in terms of the
state bank accounts rewarding about the
scope of that partial review and
motivation looks like I think is key
okay
well thank you very much from our
declaring looking close
as well thank you